[Música]
ah
normalmente cuando un profe hace una
charla sobre enseñanza es un buen
profesor está reconocido no es mi caso
tampoco es que sea yo mal profesor no
pero digamos que soy un poco como los
alumnos hay que motivarme
yo no pongo libro de texto porque ningún
libro es capaz de sentir en mi clase no
pongo deberes porque el horario escolar
no es de 24 horas y nuevos exámenes
porque cuando haces un examen no dar
clase
soy bastante crítico con la enseñanza
con los profes conmigo mismo e incluso
con la innovación educativa lo que acabo
de contar no es nada nuevo mucho
profesor lo hacen aunque todavía no es
suficiente lo que sí hago y ahí me
diferencia un poco y lo que traigo hoy
es que pongo dieces a todos mis alumnos
que son 150 alumnos
150 10 es porque pongo 10 veces
primero porque se lo merecen segundo
porque aplicó mi porcentaje de
incompetencia mía tercero porque aplicó
también el porcentaje de incompetencia
de todos los demás colegas que son
inconscientes de su incompetencia quad
cuarto porque el 10 es un mito y yo no
le tengo ni miedo ni más respeto que
cualquier otra nota
y porque con el 10 lo que hago es que
entregó toda mi confianza del alumno y
eso descubrí que es un potente revulsivo
de larga duración para su aprendizaje la
verdad es que los profes nos confundimos
todos los días a mujer es por eso que
usamos libro de texto e intentando
confundirnos y que no sea nuestra culpa
no por eso es parte de nuestra profesión
confundirnos a diario con todos los
alumnos no yo estoy en la escuela
pública la escuela de todos y de todas
en las aulas están todos y todas no hay
preselección y yo lo que no quiero es
ser un profe que seleccione y que
escribe
la innovación educativa está muy de moda
y bueno yo le pongo una pega y es que
está compitiendo con la vieja escuela
está compitiendo con la nota y si hay
nota la nota no califica la nota
descalifica que es un 10 realmente
es una paleta de verdes por las caras
que ponen algunos veo que alguno ha
sufrido alguna reforma en su vivienda
aquí son todos viernes todos cuál es el
más verde de todos
cuál es el más 10 de todos todos son
verdes el matriz no es de 0 a 10 cada
número tiene miles de matices por eso
que pongo dieces a todos la verdad es
que usarlo con muchos profesores que sí
son reconocidos en la innovación
educativa y no convencían ninguno de
ellos son muy buenos porque se dedican
en cuerpo y alma a lo que es la vocación
de la enseñanza no les convencí de
llegar hasta el punto de poner dices a
todos
nos confundimos muchos y yo encontré
además aquí en galicia una vía que es el
aprendizaje por proyectos cuando veis
esta imagen que puse en el tablón en el
hall de entrada en el instituto sabéis a
qué proyecto se refiere
la que llame de louvre no no era ese
proyecto los monumentos de parís tampoco
era así ese proyecto los monumentos de
europa tampoco en ese proyecto
me confundí no era la imagen que tenía
que haber mostrado tenía que haber
mostrado las imágenes de todas las
actividades que hemos llevado haciendo
un proyecto de reflexión sobre los
movimientos migratorios los refugiados y
contra el racismo y la xenofobia
cuántos alumnos
están en esta foto podéis contarlos
y ahora
veis alguno más
ahora lo veis mejor
vaya vaya vaya es que el don de la
observación nos cuesta y bueno pues ocho
años después este alumno que no estaba
en su sitio que no quería su sitio los
demás teníamos todos sus sitios no tiene
un problema con la fotografía pues ya no
se escondía ya no necesitaba a nadie
él solito portadas de periódico porque
fue uno de los diez invitados altet de
vancouver
bueno pues
en educación hay que tener también
paciencia el horno hay que ponerlo
kevin que ahora ya es también uno de los
organizadores de usted en españa y en
europa ya no necesita esconderse de nada
no no es propio de sí mismo no
la verdad es que soy crítico con
nosotros mismos pero tengo que reconocer
algo que somos más importantes que un
piloto de avión y a mí la vieja escuela
me explicó que a mayor responsabilidad
mayor salario y no entiendo por qué
cobro menos con piloto de avión porque
un piloto de avión como mucho en toda su
carrera va a poder estrellar a 500
personas yo lo puedo hacer todos los
años durante 40 años entonces cuando
tienes esta perspectiva
entiendes que no puede haber
sostenibilidad nunca si dejamos a una
sola persona fuera eso es imposible eso
sí que es una utopía
y quisiera acabar para que no veáis que
es un poco un rollo educativo y
trasladarlo un poco a lo que es fuera
del aula porque somos los mismos los que
estamos fuera del aula que los que
estábamos dentro no
y es el de pensar que lo que hace falta
es un país de profes no de negreros
disfrazados de profes y ya que estamos
reunidos hoy en un evento especial es
como decir que lo que nos hace falta es
un país
ted así que vamos a hacer un poco como
lo el esfuerzo de la fotografía cuando
nos veamos al final nos observaremos
todos y todos juntos
[Aplausos]